no no no no ai tuoi anno sia vogliamo la
musica voglio la musica classica per
tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo nuovo
video devo fare questa intro nostalgica
ma anche doverosa perché effettivamente
questo gioco non l'ho mai giocato e la
vogliono farci una visione sulle pd soci
domenica quindi let's roll
vediamo se mi ricordo come si fa che
figata che tu pensi che il nemico do
niente sono scarso come a me non ero
sono e scarso sul senso più bravo non so
perché ho disimparato ragazzo di
s'impara sile è normale come quando
smetti di fare palestra ma io che il
caso di fare però per dire no signori io
non me ne vado di qua affinché non
finisco suo livello quanto è vero iddio
non me ne vado non me ne vado perché
veramente devo assolutamente fini sta
roba perché non è possibile cioè mi
rifiuto veramente di essere di essere
arrivato a questo c'è proprio di non
riuscire a fare cosa ne del mio passato
da apple iphone
dammi quest'affare ti prego barca tutta
mi sembra un po eccessivo però è l'unico
modo per risolvere hanno tentato
l'attacco incredibile ci sono anche
quasi riusciti perché mi hanno spaccato
braccio ma come comunque ragazzi
complimenti perché vedo che è diventato
più difficile questa cosa qua mi fa
piacere mi fa piacere fino a un certo
punto finché non non si abbassa la mia
reputazione su sto gioco va bene allora
allora allora facciamo spiega una nuova
molto semplice un computer dalle 15 mila
euro questo affare 15 si merita di
vincere il suo happy visto che sono nel
senso che tecnica pensate che io abbia
questo e 3090 soltanto per giocare a
videogiochi con gravi commentano sono
per giocare bene a david mills quindi
devo vincere se non assetto fiorito
indietro e cioè nel senso che non mi
merito questa notte a madonna 2 donna
eccolo
proviamo un'altra chiave di lettura
secondo me il gioco incazzato perché non
lo sto facendo più non scrivi a un amico
da un sacco di tempo quelli cioè come
stai
ma la bamboo della cosa i video ho avuto
altri problemi nella mia vita è posto
sorgerà è più noti incazzare sono a
livelli che se ci parli per tutto a
posto incredibile
lui sa quello che succede per area
sixteen i've got what non è niente di
quello che pensavo ma va bene a lei ma è
fatto fatte le toux ciao difficoltà
giocare sta roba
ci manca solo che chiedevano la mano
open kamò breve o addio dell'odio del no
vabbè ragazzi che fils des ray
chi di voi vi segue da quando sono nato
lo sa di che stiamo parlando cioè le ray
che è stata na o perso i miei primi
dieci anni di vita insomma avevo già
avevo già 26 anni a 16 anni quando ho
giocato a dare bellissimo si ricordava
un po più spaventosi novara bene anche
così le scuole molto bello per vedere
che con come si è evoluta nel tempo cioè
non si è voluto per niente però ho fatto
più schifo io a giocarci con importante
questo è spenta loft of time of field
level grazie arrivederci con giovan
upwards non sono riuscito a fare quello
di prima come puoi sperare che io riesca
a fare sta roba del tour
ma non facciamoci domanda andiamo avanti
ragazzi spyphone easy giusto per
ritornare ai the ai vecchi tempi quando
riusciva a vincere despite col tifo
questo mamma mia se ci fossi riuscito
subito sarebbe stata incredibile madonna
quanto rimorchiato i tempi con altri
questa uno scherzo aspetta un attimo
aspetta un attimo aspetta un attimo
guarda lo è difficilissimo dalle caritas
impossibile portare molto più facile o
forse loro più le mani io non lo so
veramente ragazzi cioè dove vedere se
visto video però però poteva andare
anche peggio può cioè varick street
questa ex 36 stremo abbiamo fatto quello
dritto quello storto quello estremo
manca manca è più il 2 dopo porca vacca
10 10 la prova la carta igienica ma cosa
che livello è questo trovala che no no
no no qual è il problema e tipo una
sorta di bio bio nuovo il get up down
chi nostro male se la sono sbrigata
questa dove trova la carta igienica non
ho quanto ai cagato quanto è cagato
porca ai cagato aspetta perché devi
ruotare solo il gente del
complicatissimo ragazzi però vabbè ce
posso provare cosa ste cose che girano
se sta roba sporca tra uffici ok ok
ragazzi mai arrivato cosi lontano se vi
ricordo che siamo nel 2021 è il mio
computer rende giustizia a questo gioco
non lo potrei giocare
ok ok lo spezzino ed è
volte bellissimo ma che finale ragazzi
vi prego che chi genialità è piena ma
grazie ero andato oltre ero andato oltre
il traguardo pensavo di aver perso e mi
ha preso per il culo per almeno un 20
secondi buoni è stato geniale shot gun
rampe a mi posso muovere salve come
questa pizza l'ananas arrivederci
comunque è una delle battute che va
rifatto il 2013 quindi farne mox nets
box l'udc a palleggiare con pezzo di
carni non lo sa che non immagino ragazzi
sto puccini incredibile questo è un
fucile è un cannone ok lo spaccato con
la luce stand o spaccatura zuccherino
arrivederci
sarà veramente molto satisfy il suo
livello non si proietta è bellissimo è
stato eletto divertente 8 hubble paul
pool a ok qua devi fare la foto è tipo
biliardino
quanta poca voglia nel fare i livelli
quanta l'iphone il prossimo album ora
aspetta una roma così difficile come in
crimea troppo easy questo collage più
complicato infatti si vede però
attenzione questa me la sento
questo importante sentirsela poi amo un
grassi imposto ma ci sono un sacco di
livelli di amh un gas ragazzi ma cos'è
killed è imposto al visuales difficoltà
make e con l'ammazzo spiega mi ami
ammazzato lui una cosa come faccio
rivolgersi ecco ma non era così
complicato come livello però sono uscito
a morire la prima volta proviamo a fare
anche plain crescer vai mò perché brain
crash esatto era uno dei livelli più più
famosi dietro dall'inizio
non so se è un po diversa un po diverso
ovvero un altro blend ma c era era un
format sulla tedesca diventata state
conosciuto qui non sei più pagato
nessuno ma a me piaceva un sacco e non
sono sopravvissuto ma grazie per avermi
dato la vittoria grazie mille impossible
de trane si va a concludere una delle
puntate e si va a concludere una della
nostra nuova nuova cioè non capita non
devo concluso del video quindi fammi
farmi fare una bella figura per favore
grazie stavolta sono partito buono
questa è buona
sto volando jack oddio non so dove sta
cadendo negando una idea quanto 2 ascom
livello yes ko è stato bellissimo
ragazzi questa e bisogna più di oggi
fatemi sapere se volete altri questo
pareggio col nuovo quindi potrebbero
piacervi
fatemi sapere per i commenti cosa ne
pensate questi sono ragazzi avete più
sull'argomento mi piace è anche visto
cha cui nota descrizione senso che si
siede
vediamo come sempre al prossimo video
[Musica]